fentanyl a drug 50 times stronger than
heroin with just two milligrams enough
to kill and right now it's feeling the
worst drug crisis in the history of the
United States tonight to examine where
it's coming from why it's so dangerous
and how police parents and even schools
are trying to stop it we have an
eyewitness report from inside the secret
Labs cooking up the drug in Mexico and
meet the drug cartels making millions
from Fentanyl
50 kilos would kill everyone in London
and everyone in Los Angeles
it's incredible to think people even put
this into their bodies
we joined the police targeting the Gans
and the paramedics racing to bring
people back from the brink of death
in America the effects are Stark with
addicts reduced to a zombie-like state
on the streets of some of the country's
biggest cities I've never seen anything
like it I meet regular people Square
Joe's on their way to work and they'll
stop hang out with me and try this drug
for the first time and then leave their
life
we meet the families broken by fentanyl
now determined to stop more young lives
being lost to the drug
he was 16 years old 17 years old through
a pill she was trying to use to relieve
her anxiety and sleep but it's the drug
the drug is so addictive and it steals
lives
so what can be done about it we'll ask
the director of drug control in the
White House
[Music]
good evening welcome to a Sky News
special program investigating the lethal
rise of fentanyl 50 times more powerful
than heroin 100 times more potent than
morphine fentanyl is a multi-million
dollar business spanning the globe and
fueling an addiction epidemic in the U.S
that has killed thousands of drug users
in parts of the US law enforcement has
lost the fight to control the deadly
drug and it's already on its way over
here
well Sky News brings you the story from
our team across the North and Central of
America will speak to our chief
correspondent Stuart Ramsey who's been
tracing the production line of fentanyl
in Mexico Martha Kellner joins us from a
neighborhood in San Francisco that is
overwhelmed with drug dependency and
from Texas Mark Stone reports on the
American teenagers dying from taking the
drug
but first tonight to Northwest Mexico
where Sky News witnessed firsthand how
one drug cartel manufactures super
strength fentanyl using chemicals
smuggled from China our chief
correspondent Stuart Ramsey sent us this
from a small village on Mexico's Pacific
Coast fishing boats with powerful
engines speed through estuaries leading
to the ocean
it's early evening but they moved before
dark
on board are members of the Sinaloa drug
cartel one of the most powerful in
Mexico
they're heading to a rendezvous point to
pick up a shipment the cartel says has
been smuggled here from China
on an islet in water too shallow for
Mexico's Security Forces to use their
vessels a man helps load plastic Jerry
cans filled with chemicals known as
precursors
they are the crucial ingredients that
make the opioid drug Fentanyl
this is the first part of a process that
makes the cartel millions of dollars
but fuels an opioid epidemic that's
killing thousands of drug users in the
United States they move quickly Mexican
Marines are always near and drones are a
constant threat
they head to shore
the chemicals are loaded into a car to
be whisked away to a safe house
directions are given to us to join the
gang later that night
the back streets of culiacan the Sinaloa
cartel's headquarters are controlled by
Cartel gunmen
we'll watch constantly as we drive to
the Stash House
the precursors are already here
this is one of the cartel's most senior
players he's in charge of Distributing
the precursors to the fentanyl making
labs
there's one Consignment he told me can
make half a ton of the drug
they do this every week
[Music]
it's a huge business
foreign
[Music]
labs are spread across the state of
Sinaloa in towns Villages and the
countryside
we're guided up a remote Hillside
hidden beneath trees and tarpaulin
sheets is a lab where the synthetic
opioid drug is made
it's highly toxic even breathing in the
fumes here is lethal
the U.S drug enforcement agency says
pure fentanyl is so dangerous even a
microscopic dose can be lethal this gang
estimates that they make about 50 kilos
of fentanyl a week
it's incredibly dangerous and toxic
stuff
give you some perspective 50 kilos would
kill everyone in London pretty amazing
right except in fact 50 kilos would kill
everyone in London and everyone in Los
Angeles it's incredible to think people
even put this into their bodies but it's
big business and they're making a lot of
money
it's going to take a few hours to make
pure fentanyl the two gang members who
create the drug leave their guns on a
tree branch as they work through three
processes
essentially they're adding the Chinese
precursors acid and a variety of other
chemicals they won't reveal to us to
make a porridge-like mash that is then
re-diluted and mixed again
they have no qualms about making this
lethal cocktail
America
Americas are on a Wanted list because so
many people are dying in America
because of fentanyl do you care about
that
each part of the process concludes with
a centrifuge removing the water as they
get nearer to the end
the most important people in this whole
process are of course
the men who make the Phantom they call
themselves the cooks and in fact they
they actually pay others to teach them
how to do it it's very much like a
professional chef they don't do it just
by time
they do it by how it looks what it feels
like if you like and that's how they
know when it's it's each process and
there's three processes that's when they
know that it's done of course at the end
of the third process it's pure attention
there is a constant mixing stirring and
drying of the product in and out of
sheets and bags before they're finally
happy and indicate they are done they
never take off their gloves respirators
or aprons
pure fentanyl is emptied into a bowl
they break it into pieces
and move it into the sun to start drying
at another location the now Drive
fentanyl is ground into powder in a
smoothie maker
the drug is carefully weighed to a
single kilo and loaded into a plastic
bag and then completely wrapped in thick
tape
this Consignment will join another batch
of kilo bags and is destined for the
United States
it's placed in a secret locked
compartment the cartel was installed in
a pickup
the journey North now begins its
destination Tijuana on the United States
border
once here the drug is swapped into a car
with American number plates and joins
the traffic that constantly crosses
between the two countries the cartel
accepts some Consignments will be
intercepted but not every car can be
searched
dealers in the United States will start
cutting the fentanyl one kilo can
quickly become 10 kilos and the profits
multiply
if the demand is there this deadly trade
seems Unstoppable
Stewart is in Tijuana for us tonight
Stuart good to have you with us other
drug cartels winning this war
well they certainly don't seem to be
able to be stopped I think what you have
to always remember with the cartels
they're extremely sophisticated educated
organizations they've got a lot of
employees here and a lot of people
abroad and they have close contacts with
other crime gangs so they really are all
over the world and I think one of the
problems the authorities really is that
even if they arrest some of the bosses
they're just replaced and then the
business goes on so it is very very
difficult to stall
you're in Tijuana for us tonight just
tell us why is that City so Central to
this story
it
it's quite simple really it's because
it's it's right next door to the United
States there's a huge amount of traffic
that passes between the countries on a
daily basis so if you like it's a sort
of massive uh Distribution Hub for the
cartels the problem for the city is that
as a result of this there are three
cartels effectively fighting each other
for control of the streets as a result
it's one of the most dangerous cities in
the world there's about 2 000 murders
every year here that equates on average
to six a day it's quite remarkable just
a quick warning uh this report contains
flashing images
stops in Tijuana a Red Cross Ambulance
is called to a shooting in one of the
most gang-infested areas of the city
in through the streets ahead of us a
crime scene
National Guard and police are already
trying to take control of the area
zolma Cruz grabs her gear she is a
paramedic who is used to the menacing
presence of the security forces and the
stairs of locals many of whom identify
with or are part of the cartel
she joins colleagues already treating a
man shot in the head
another attempted Gangland execution
three cartels are vying for control of
Tijuana it's the Gateway for drug and
people smuggling to the USA
the trade in the opioid drug fentanyl is
fueling an illegal drug epidemic in the
U.S and a streetwar inside Mexico
there's been an upsurge in
deaths gang members being identified and
shot this man here he's very serious
he's stable but he is critical
fentanyl many believe it's right at the
heart of all of this it's a growing
business and as a result of it the
fighting between the gangs is getting
more and more vicious
another call this time a fentanyl
overdose
a fast drive through the city the Red
Cross carry the antidote to fentanyl
poisoning one of the most toxic drugs in
the world
it's called Narcan and it can save the
lives of those who are almost dead
the fire brigade are giving first aid as
paramedic Alan Leon administers the
Narcan
time is critical they want to see if
they've caught the victim in time
watch this it is incredible the drug has
just been given to Juan through a drip
he's talking he's shocked he's alive his
family hug him as he recovers he's a
lucky man
fentanyl use fentanyl trafficking gang
wars death and murder the ambulance
Crews see it all every day this is gang
violence there's a lot of it linked to
the fentanyl business do you think
foreign
ERS red light district is the most
public location for the Cartel Wars and
the use and sale of fentanyl on the
streets it's constantly patrolled by
police and National Guard but they
aren't beating the criminal activity
here
The Gangs make a fortune from drugs and
the sex industry 24 hours a day it's why
they fight so hard to hold or take
territory the police say the cartels are
only interested in making money they
don't care what fentanyl does to people
[Music]
is
problematica
if this district is Ground Zero for the
fentanyl trade in Mexico then this city
is the launch pad for the export of
fentanyl to America but also to the rest
of the world
Stu Ramsey Sky News Tijuana
or from Tijuana the drug flows across
the border into the United States which
is now in the grip of a fentanyl crisis
and the drug is 50 times stronger than
heroin 100 times stronger than morphine
the most recent figures show synthetic
opioids including fentanyl killed more
than 70 000 Americans in 2021 accounting
for the majority of Overdose deaths in
the US now in the same year fentanyl was
the leading killer of Americans aged 18
to 49.
well our correspondent Martha Kellner is
in San Francisco's tenderloin District
an area that the drug has already taken
a hold of
Arthur just talked to us about the human
cost of this fentanyl crisis
yeah it is Stark here I am as you
mentioned in San Francisco's tenderloin
District which is the heart of the
city's downtown I'm a couple of streets
away from the tech industry which has
made San Francisco its home United
Nations Plaza is around the corner it is
an incredibly wealthy City yet this is
the picture here it is very very Stark
Brazen open out drug use here I've seen
people taking drugs in front of tourists
walking past even in front of police and
Fentanyl overdose deaths are on the rise
here 200 people in the past three months
have lost their lives in France San
Francisco to fentanyl but speaking to
people you get a sense of the horror of
that beyond the statistics many of the
people most of the people in fact that
I've spoken to have lost friends
recently to fentanyl some in front of
their very eyes I've been struck though
by just how much people want to tell
their story they want America they want
the world to know about the horror of
fentanyl addiction and being in this
city you just get a sense of how much
they're disturbed by how this drug has
taken a hold of this place
it's a normal afternoon on the doorstep
of San Francisco's main government
building a snapshot of America's
fentanyl crisis
it doesn't just look stuck
an average of one person every 10 hours
dies in this city of a fentanyl overdose
it's often here in the drug ravage
tenderloin District
are you a fentanyl user absolutely I've
been a hero I've been an opiate addict
for probably 10 years Trevor used to
inject heroin but fentanyl he says is a
different beast and he wants everyone to
know I mean the fact that this isn't a
main issue I mean on TV every night is
insane to us I've never seen anything
like it I meet regular people Square
Joe's on their way to work and they'll
stop hang out with me and try this drug
for the first time and then leave their
life literally not not leave from that
moment on they're just out here with us
is that what fentanyl does to some
people it's insane I've never seen
anything like it no one has what's it
doing to the streets
yeah I mean it's turning everybody into
you know a crazy violent drug addict
we're doing an interview I know but do
that somewhere else y'all smoking crack
right here
we're interrupted by Private Security
asking them to move out of the view of
the nursery
this is a city divided on how to deal
with the scourge of drugs
some want the streets swept others
prefer a more compassionate health-based
approach
no one wants to end up with a
manslaughter charge because someone
dives from their product Jeff is a
former drug dealer and says testing is
the answer two stripes would be a not a
negative result once one strip would be
a positive result yep so there's a
second line showing up right now simple
strip tests are now being used by
dealers and users to check for fentanyl
it's sometimes contaminates Other Drug
supplies Like Cocaine I know you work
with one of the largest Mexican street
gangs helping test their cocaine to make
sure it doesn't have fentanyl or traces
of fence on it how how does that work
yeah customers start to notice that
people are dying from a batch of cocaine
in that the autopsy results are showing
that it's because of an opioid overdose
no one's buying that cocaine anymore I
mean it just doesn't make Financial
sense to kill your customer base
across town beside a homeless encampment
a charity has set up
they hand out clean syringes and
overdose reversal treatments how has
fentanyl transformed your home people
are dying a lot more people are dying
and and it's in a lot of the drug Supply
and people are doing it without knowing
they're doing it and it's it's made
substance use
um
horrifyingly
deadly
it's difficult to believe at times that
this is one of America's great historic
cities home to more billionaires than
anywhere on Earth
this is two streets from the
headquarters of Twitter but it's an
open-air drug Market it is a tragedy
with no easy resolution
foreign
to know as well that the city's minority
population here has been particularly
hard hit a third of those 200 people in
the past three months who have died in
San Francisco of fentanyl overdoses were
black despite them making up just five
percent of the City's population and
some may look at San Francisco and
wonder why a city which is so rich
cannot get a grip on this incredibly
destructive problem and it's a
complicated picture and the city is
divided on how to deal with it as I was
mentioning there some people prefer a
more compassionate health-based approach
others want tougher more aggressive
policing and on that note the California
governor Gavin Newsom he has drafted in
the National Guard so come and try and
clean up this area although wandering
around here over the past two days I've
not actually seen any of the National
Guard on the streets a harm reduction
Center which opened not far from here
year which offered clean syringes and a
safe place for people to take drugs that
was shut down in December after
Community opposition other things that
people are trying which you saw there in
my report strict testing of drugs to
make sure that other drugs are not
contaminated by fentanyl just a tiny
tiny Speck of fentanyl is enough to kill
they also have
um those null can supplies which you saw
in Stewart's report and which offer an
immediate reversal to overdoses an
incredible intervention treatment malcan
many people here are carrying in
carrying in the back of their bags to
help their friends should their friends
have an overdose so people are trying to
find Solutions but quite frankly Nothing
is Stopping the huge supply of fentanyl
which is reaching San Francisco and
having such a corrosive devastating
effect here
okay Martha for now thank you
and now the impact on American
communities are U.S correspondent Mark
stone is in Texas for us mark
Kamali we were in Philadelphia
Philadelphia uh back in February
February February where we saw such
similar scenes to that that you've just
seen in Martha kellner's report fentanyl
sometimes cut with things even more
deadly that are now emerging is it is in
cities right across this country but we
had heard that it was well beyond that
it was in small towns like this a
beautiful small town in southern Texas
not the place you would expect to find
such a deadly drug but it is here it is
in schools it is in homes and it is
devastating societies like this
we'd arranged to meet Stephanie and her
family at a park in Austin
then she said she'd bring some others
too
because fentanyl has broken so many here
we lost our son Tucker Rowe my
granddaughter Victoria Joanne I lost my
son Stephen James on February 17th of
this year so he was 16 years old 17
years old make no assumptions about this
drug there is no typical victim it is a
poison and it is killing Young Americans
up and down this country and she took
maybe what she thought was a Xanax
through a pill she was trying to use to
relieve her anxiety and sleep that was
unfortunately laced with fentanyl we
found her the next day
we were
what is it 20 feet down the hall asleep
while she passed away and we had no idea
you can take your pick of devastated
communities here
just to the south of Austin is the town
of Kyle
and we're out with the local police
chief
this started less than 18 months ago and
when it did start it it came with a
vengeance
and it struck multiple families just in
a matter of months sometimes a matter of
weeks we're a couple of hours here from
America's Southern border what is in
Mexico now
in a few short hours can be in the hands
of our residents here in this part of
the state in schools like that in
schools like that
last week a child overdosed in this
classroom It Is tragically telling that
they knew what to do so when we get
called we get called to a classroom
usually you can tell there's a sense of
urgency over our radios when we're
listening so when we get there we look
at the students sometimes they're blue
they're not responsive by any means they
have a the death snore it's really scary
to hear
we just give the Narcan as quick as
possible get them on the ground and make
sure there's a pulse if not we have to
initiate CPR
sometimes or if there is a pulse we can
kind of resuscitate them back with
rescue breeding goodness and is that
student okay as far as I know yes
the young girl survived thanks to this a
reversal treatment Narcan they keep it
on hand
but often it's not enough in this school
district they have lost five students
since last summer children
it could be anybody close to you it
could be anybody around you and it just
hurts
knowing that it could be you
you know covet and the depression the
anxiety that children faced and that
people are still living with today and
not combined with this eat relatively
easy to get and lethal drug is really
what's causing it to be so hard on our
community
Jerry skrocky is the school district
security director I think we're being
successful on that first time user I
think that that we're that they're
getting the message and I think that
parents and those kids are hating us
where I think we are not reaching is
those kids who already are addicted and
I think that goes back hand in hand to
the the lack of resources and the lack
of mental health treatment absolutely
but you can feel the heaviness here a
burden beyond anything they should face
nobody wants to be working an overdose
on anyone but let alone a child
and it happening in the middle of a
school day
um it's just
sorry
it's rough yeah it really is
this stuff is a game changer because
you're dealing with uh sometimes 14 15
16 year old kids that are dying from
just one one blue pill
Tommy Villanueva leads the drug busts in
the community he doesn't want to be
identified but he can reveal what
they've seized these are the pills that
the kids are taking those are the most
popular ones that we're seeing
sometimes they're cutting them in half
and or a quarter or just taking a sliver
correct would you feel Tommy that this
is a this is a battle you're winning are
you are you getting on top of this or
are you up against it no sir we're up
against it they're we're not winning it
at all uh we're managing what we do have
and what we do find and the information
we do get
um
but no we're not winning this is just a
small fraction of what is here what
we've seen what we've seized back in
Austin in the park Dusk and they were
still telling us their stories but it's
the drug the drug is so addictive and
it's so powerful and it steals lives and
that's what it did to our son
[Music]
he was a great big brother and um
he was just always there
they are bound by grief and a drug
that's killing Americans in record
numbers
we're going to continue to fight and
honor his name he will not be just
another statistic not as long as I'm
living
and I am afraid to tell you that we've
just had a tragic update from the school
that you saw in that report there they
have confirmed that another child a 15
year old girl has died from an overdose
a young girl who would have thought that
she was taking a painkiller or a
sleeping pill or was just experimenting
like kids do and she died
Mark for now thank you
I'm pleased to say we're now joined by
Dr Rahul Gupta who is director of the
office for National Drug control policy
is responsible for coordinating drug
policy in the United States so Dr Gupta
thank you very much for your time and
thank you for being with us this evening
000 deaths a year the biggest killer of
people aged 18 to 49 children dying kids
dying daily as Mark just told us why is
the US government failing to protect its
citizens and its children from Fentanyl
well let's first uh talk about why this
is happening it's happening because we
lack a uh continuous treatment
infrastructure prediction it's happening
because the traffickers are continuing
to profit out of in a dispassionate way
out of vulnerable Americans and that's
exactly from day one the President Biden
has been focused on and what we are
trying to do is build an addiction
treatment infrastructure while going
after the trafficking and the profits
and we're making some some of the most
historic progress as you talk about
about harm reduction expanding treatment
and then making sure that we're going
after the bad guys to hold them
accountable I mean but all of that is
going to do nothing for the parents of
that 15 year old in Kyle Texas who's
just died from an overdose because of
this stuff
that's exactly right and you know I have
children I'm a parent I'm also a
physician somebody who has himself
attended funerals of people and sobbed
part of the reason is that we don't want
this to happen we want to make sure that
my own high school now I'm seeing
overdoses in the Washington area it is
important that we meet where young
people are make sure that they are aware
of the dangers of getting pills that are
not from a pharmacy or from a doctor and
make sure that they're carrying naloxone
or Narcan that's exactly what we're
doing when we put out a social media
campaign from the White House with that
Council to make young people aware of
these dangers the fact is today that
ordering a pill online whether it's
Adderall or Xanax or anything the
counterfeit nature of that is more
dangerous than playing russial roulette
with your life and we want to make sure
that every young person Across America
is aware of that yeah it's important
that message gets out some 46 billion
dollars has been assigned to try and
fight this issue how much of that is
going towards stopping it coming across
the border and how much of that is going
into that treatment prevention
infrastructure you talked about
yeah that's a good question we have
about 57 of this is going towards
treatment and rest is going towards
addressing the supply side and what
we're trying to do is two things first
making sure we have a plan what we do
now we're seeing about eight months of
flattening or decrease in these historic
numbers we get we're not there we have a
long way to go secondly we're trying to
make sure that the world Community knows
that this is the synthetic issue is a
global threat there's three types of
countries in this world right now today
unfortunately one those who have a
synthetic drugs like fentanyl problem
and know about it like United States
others who have a problem don't yet know
about it and the third category is those
who are going to have this problem in
the future of synthetic drugs this has
really become a global Menace and it's
really important for United States as we
are doing to lead on this effort because
the trafficking is becoming more
internationalized as well yeah and I'm
glad that you touched on that Dr Gupta
whether the UK fall in those categories
do you think we've got a synthetic drug
problem now we don't know about it or is
it coming
well first of all we know that uh you
know I've met with them my colleagues
and counterparts in the UK uh there's
obviously opioids problem like heroin
and others uh but is will not be a
surprise that it also become Falls
victim to a synthetic problem and that
is why
um you know my counterparts in the UK
are very active in supporting working
with the United States as are many other
countries across the globe to move
forward to make sure that we are taking
proactive steps not only reactive but
proactive steps to both have
surveillance monitoring but also then
denying the profits that these
trafficking organizations survive on
both operating capital and profits we
deny them those in order to beat this uh
particular crisis
okay Dr Rahel group to do appreciate
your time and expertise thank you very
much for being with us thank you
now from drug factories in the mountains
of northwest Mexico to the classrooms of
Texas are special Sky news reports has
revealed the scale of the fight against
fentanyl the drug is killing thousands
of Americans but as our reporting shows
as long as there is demand cartels will
continue to manufacture and distribute
it and the cartel Insurance report told
Sky News they're already selling to
dealers in the UK the question for
authorities here can they be stopped and
while efforts to crack down on the drugs
availability go on its victims keep
dying we'll end tonight with the voices
of just some of the people caught up in
America's fentanyl crisis
I've never seen anything like it I'll
meet regular people Square Joe's on
their way to work and they'll stop hang
out with me and try this drug for the
first time and then leave their life
literally not not leave from that moment
on they're just out here with us it's
turning everybody into you know a crazy
violent drug addict
[Applause]
people are dying a lot more people are
dying and and it's in a lot of the drug
Supply and people are doing it without
knowing they're doing it and it's made
substance use horrifyingly
deadly
we lost our son Tucker Rowe my
granddaughter Victoria Joanne my son
Stephen James he was 16 years old we
found her the next day we were
what is it 20 feet down the hall asleep
while she passed away the drug is so
addictive and it steals lives